I now drive an electric car you do a guy
and I understand you got an electric car
recently were you liking the experience
uh I love it when it has electricity in
it it's been great when it's got
electricity and it's been great
what do you mean whenever not charge it
no when I first got it we didn't have an
outlet in the garage so I was kind of
like stealing power wherever I could to
kind of keep it barely charged you know
like at work I would plug it into the
trailer or whatever yeah
little by little it started to whittle
down and until I went to a doctor's
appointment up at UCLA and went to get
out of the car and the door didn't open
and the windows wouldn't roll down
because they operate on electricity and
the car didn't have any electricity in
it and it was not a cool day it was warm
enough that I was starting to sweat
couldn't get out of the car so it's her
I mean that seems like a kind of a
dangerous situation your apt in a hot
car and you can't get out yeah so I was
get a little panicky and starting to
sweat and just then a tour group came
around the corner and recognized me in
the car basically like this at the
window was like and came up and I mean I
was sweating in a car with my hands on
the window and came up to the side of
the car and we're like uh you know
knocking were like we take a picture
yeah yeah and I was like uh and they
were like no just a quick picture I was
like I don't I I can't you were trying
to get the window down so I think to
them they basic I looked like the
biggest Hollywood [ __ ] a guy who is
sitting in his car sweating like he's
been on 72 hours of cocaine yeah
and and then either never bothered to
learn how to open the window of a car or
has like a window guy who does that
yeah and who just was on his break or
something you have a crank window and
you have a guy you've hired it how are
you so that you don't have to do it
Craig's gone guys yeah so you will never
explain to those people those people are
gonna tell everybody yeah that you're
the biggest jerk yeah he wouldn't bother
to even lean over and roll his window
down yeah and then what's interesting is
later I died in thanks my favorite part
is ya know here - I never had a ghost on
before yeah actually that's not true
that's wait about what an electric car
doesn't the UH that seems really
dangerous you've got to get a better one
so that if the power fails you're not
trapped in a coffin um some of this may
also be operator error I think it's fair
to assume that any modern car company
that's making an electric car that right
you know there's a way to get out yeah
I'm just not great at you and you at it
yeah like I would go into an escape room
that had like one puzzle one thing and I
would sit there for an hour
I think have you done an escape room I
have yeah I like it I really did I only
got out by cheating Iommi
yeah I just basically kicked the door
down if we actually shot it for a remote
there I just hated it I absolutely hated
it I don't know if anyone here has done
an escape room but they just have like
clues like the number seven and I'm like
I don't I just want out of here I want
to go I think I took an axe and smashed
the door down good the time that I did
it we I went with a bunch of of people
who do in who do improv like well you
know we thought oh this was going to be
really hilarious it was incredible how
serious it got immediately people got
very very focused it was a dare dare I
say boring and and then at the end we
finally got to a thing that we thought
was the end and a door opened and and
that was it I mean like we were like
banging on the wall and stuff and we
were like I guess we didn't win and
we were leaving and the woman goes no
you won the monitor was out it was
supposed to have confetti on it right so
you're gonna ruin for six hours you
solve it and then a woman just goes like
yeah I know yeah we'll see you later
keep going we go we got more people here
for the confetti now it's the worst idea
ever those rooms
you